kamil welcome to AEI it's great to be
back Christina oh my goodness but do you
know that 21 years ago I don't it was
today but close to today we made and we
were interviewed by Ben wattenberg for
the AEI program think-tank which aired
on PBS and the question was has feminism
gone too far and I looked at the
transcript and it it's amazing because
all the things we are saying are truer
today than they were 21 years ago about
the excesses of feminism the victimology
the male bashing that the panic over
sexuality at the time 21 years ago we
were we were confident that it would be
corrected it was simply too too mad to
succeed but it's still here I know well
Christina we sent up early warnings you
heroically in the late 1980s were in
direct confrontation with women's
studies and professors at a time when
it's philosophy yes at a time when I
could not get published okay and finally
after my first book sexual persona was
released in 1990 you wrote to me and
told me of your problems okay and we've
discovered each other as allies and in
that art our status it seems to me as
truth tellers okay is historically okay
I'm challenged of it I think that people
are going to start to wake up and to
realize if they'd listened to us to
begin with we wouldn't have these
problems now we wouldn't end
it was so obvious to me I was
criticizing the women's the the feminist
theorists at the American Philosophical
Association and what they were writing
at the time was was just warmed over
Marxism it with so much animus to
American society to to men to everything
to art to beauty and it seemed to me
that it wouldn't take long for it to
correct itself
it was never corrected and what happened
is you and I we did I believe won the
argument in the you know the in in the
journalists agreed with us and the court
of public opinion was on our side they
won all the assistant professor ships
they just quietly worked they didn't
care about criticism because all
criticism is by definition backlash well
a lot of people drop out of graduate
school
they're the really free thinkers you
know the independent minds couldn't take
the kind of conformism and the pc
ideology that they had to kowtow to and
I got letters like that from the once I
was known in the early 90s
letters came from all over the country
if I'm from a former graduate students
who said they knew they had no future in
the profession okay because of Mille
kind of brain-dead attitude you had a
servile sycophantic attitude you had to
have to certainly received opinions
absolutely in in the what in our
interview 21 years ago you mentioned the
sort of Kremlin esque you know feeling
of in feminism is a Kremlin like
environment so much censorship and the
excommunication and so forth and
students today don't realize that there
had been this this you know kind of
purge of anyone who was a dissident I
happen to have tenure when I started
criticizing it but if it would be career
diminishing or career annihilating to
criticize feminism even more so today
right well when I was a graduate student
at Yale which was 1968 to 1972 I was the
only person doing a dissertation on sex
okay at the Graduate School okay and I
probably getting a job you know because
of it I was the only openly gay person
at the Yale graduate school okay a lot
of closeted people and I didn't have a
sex life okay I thought it was important
to me to put to put doing gay identity
out there about 20 from the very start
okay s feminism's ideology could be
cohered and solidified I was I could not
have a single conversation okay with a
feminist either inside or outside the
Academy they out they couldn't stand
again just what you say anti-art okay
anti rock and roll with that's not a
Rolling Stones okay they would not take
seriously anything that has to do with
biology and hormones or anything like
that
I was completely ostracized but I belong
to the pro-sex wing of feminism also
pro-pro beauty pro fashion Pro Hollywood
all of these things were in her glamour
Pro glamour but then thanks to Madonna
there was this new dissident wing in the
90s which one okay the pro-sex wing a
feminine one but now when we want one of
these gains but the institutionally
entrenched
we're a feminist you know mizar's yeah I
have brought it all back to school
our one again all the new freedoms we
won in the 90s and the pro-sex
insurgency are gone again I mean it's
it's amazing and and it's a it's a kind
of access of of intolerance with Dean's
and fanatical young feminists
and-and-and the United States government
because the Department of Education has
sent this directive to all the schools
that they have to clamp down on harasses
and they end and so forth and they've
defined it so broadly that it includes
you know if you overhear someone telling
an off-color joke you can bring them up
on charges of harassment so we have this
little reign of terror this hyper
Puritanism it's as though you know
George Orwell's Junior anti-sex League
has occupied feminists it's truly
Stalinist absolutely now I take a very
extreme view which is that it is that
colleges and universities should never
interfere in any way with the social
lives of the students it's up to the
students to regulate themselves if a
crime is truly committed it must go to
the police I would stop okay if
universities would confine themselves to
education and not to the surveillance
okay of students private lives now it
might not our generation won these
freedoms it was in local parentis when
we arrived in calculus right at varietal
ours that's right my young men wouldn't
be allowed in your room and then there
were if they were there well this was
right before I got to college but they
you had to have all of your feet on the
ground at one time you you look through
your door people managed to do things
well in 1964 when I arrived in college
our women's dorm the girls had to sign
in at 11 o'clock at night whereas the
men could run free all night long okay
so we are the ones who demanded that the
authority figures get out of a you want
to be as free and as wild as the boys
and they said to us no the world is
dangerous we need to protect you from
rape and what we said was give us the
freedom to risk rape okay these are the
freedoms that we won and now two younger
generation of girls want the parental
figures back in okay it is deeply
Stalinist is deeply infantilizing is
deeply reactionary has nothing to do
with feminism famously it's fainting
couch Victorian ladies mooning
on their chairs and have you've heard
about the safe spaces young women I gave
a lecture at Oberlin and Georgetown last
a year ago and they organized safe
spaces for students who were triggered
by you know it was a philosophy
professor was going to induce PTSD
because of my I what they objected to is
that I might have some ideas that
invalidate their experience their
institutionalizing neuroses it's what
they're doing it's absolutely madness
and have you heard of you heard the
phase or the fashion on campus now is
called intersectional feminism and it's
supposedly very progressive and it's
going to take feminism to a place where
it it is it's taking account of women
with multiple marginalized identities on
and on but all of the women the
practitioners seem to meet at the
intersection of propaganda and and
neurosis and rage and they're bullying
people it's either using feminism now
they're telling men check your
priveledge and well I think it's a good
idea that you're dead to feminism be
critiqued by class issues because what I
have said all along is that what is
being demanded is a kind of bourgeois
protection okay a white middle-class
girl okay a kind of style okay the
perfect little girl emerging from her
parents living room wants the same kind
of protections on the college campus or
I've always felt there was a bourgeois
element in this I was never sufficiently
critiqued and that what I see on the
street are Latino women african-american
women who may be middle-class but have a
working-class background as I did isn't
telling the incremental immigrant family
who are able to handle themselves on the
street able to speak back don't mind
having strong voices and strong gestures
well intersectionality started with
those women so it was a group of
african-american women who were just set
up with the women's movement attending
only to the you know needs of highly
professional middle class upper middle
class women but it has been appropriated
by mostly middle-class white women on
the campus so safe space was actually a
word that was used in black for early
news black feminism is where
our black women could just and Hispanic
went places where they could just talk
to each other and they weren't censored
and they didn't they could speak their
minds but now it means a place where for
example young women at Brown University
if there's a debate that upsets them
they flee to a safe space where they it
was described in the New York Times by
Judith Shula it's they had coloring
books crayons tapes of frolicking
puppies bubbles I mean this is what
feminism has come to that's what
education has come to okay they
absolutely know the definition down it
their therapeutic what can say it's
therapeutic resorts Oh what education
has turned into oh yes they have feeling
circles and they they have reflection
journals and they I mean it's it's this
odd mix of therapy and and anger because
it's their the the good word for this
style of activism that called them cry
bullies and it because they combined
they're both victim and victimizer and
they sort of do to other people these
these these new this new style campus
intersectionality they actually do to
other people what they claim was done to
them they they treat people they
objectify and they stereotype and they
demonize and then they try to get people
punished well Christina this is coming
from the public schools all right it's
coming from their public school
education which was devoid of knowledge
of world history and world geography and
it is nothing but navel-gazing
and and the diversity training and and
and being in all kinds of instructions
about how about about social interaction
when in fact if they were if the the
atrocities of history were revealed to
young people they would be able to put
their own little they've hurt feelings
into perspective perspective they have
no perspective you know and I think
these anti-bullying programs they're
they are learning that even the
slightest insult is a major event you
must bring in the adults it was terrible
he called me a name so they come to
college thinking that if someone
disagrees with them or says something
that's distressing but it's a you know a
catastrophe no this is this way I called
my feminism Amazon feminism I've called
it
drag-queen feminism street-smart
feminism because the drag queens of old
knew how to handle themselves on the
street okay they could be a
six-foot-tall
you know african-american guy okay in a
dress okay and he know how to pull off
his high heels and defend himself on the
streets okay and what a tongue they had
cetera and now everything is about
weakening students not strengthening
them oh it's exactly that and and now
let's talk about the young men can you
imagine being a young man on campus
today and what i see happening is just
the way society used to police the
sexuality of gay people it's now sort of
open season on the sexuality of
heterosexual male they're monitored
they're policed and demonize and
neutered there's noted by the time they
get to the Ivy League they've been
neutered everything's been stripped off
of them they've been made to feel
ashamed of anything
vir I'll okay they have nothing to
identify with they're taught their
masculinity is a pathology in need of a
cure and then it's offered to them in
these Gender Studies programs and it's
not just gender studies now this this
the this philosophy that demonizes men
it's it's throughout the curriculum and
you're absolutely right it's going on in
the high school as well yeah it's coming
early on okay so you have in some people
wonder why are video games so violent
okay why is there so much porn on your
on the web why because because
the imagination is being repressed and
censored okay and and in forcibly
cleansed of anything that's
authentically animalistic or sexy or you
know a vibrant okay so you have all of
the imaginative energy of the universe
now going into these other forms and
when they where becomes much more
violent and when people see it they go
oh this is so atrocious and so awful
well guess what okay you you've made a
whole area of life impermissible you
made all kinds of human desires and
fantasies impermissible and so it's or
today it has to come out someplace and
that's where it is that's right and and
what happened last year was a group of
cultural critics from is liberal arts
colleges started writing for magazines
for video games that it meant in
websites that address and they started
these cultural critics started to attack
the gamers and tell them that their
games were sexist and that they were
contributing to the rape culture and and
the gamers were not like the
the young men at the Ivy League the
gamers fought back huh this became known
as gamergate that the press has
completely misunderstood it and defamed
the k-mers they were just defending a
hobby that they loved and I made a video
about them in my factual feminist series
and defended the gamers and then they
started to call me based mom and I like
I am a mom and being based means being
sort of authentic genuine no-nonsense
and and cool so that's good and so I'm
based mom on Twitter you I've been
talking about you and sending out your
things they call you a based goddess Oh
for heaven sakes fantastic so the gamers
they appreciate what we're doing because
they had to fight the battle all by
themselves they were confronted in there
there are subcultures out there groups
of people that you know hobbyists who
read comic books and now these gender
critics are coming in they're not just
in the Universities they're in the all
the subcultures and making turning him
into very unhappy places but they made a
mistake when they went after the gamers
because the gamers fought back and the
gamers know a thing or two about winning
they like to win the entire world of
animation and video games and cartooning
this is the realm of pure imagination
and it must be protected
it's like art okay is it's the word at
the art and it's it in the world of
gaming is diverse and if women don't if
groups of women I mean there's a small
group of very cool gamers it's mostly
guys in a small group of women but if
women want I don't know if they want
video games about Downton Abbey or
something they can make them I mean it
when you see it's like when you are not
exposed to complex works of art like
dust IFC gave me for example alright
then you end up with a simplistic view
of human life you see this utopian view
somehow everything can be you know like
butterflies and birds and so on and
they'd the dark side okay of human
existence it's completely missing okay
from these from these people's
experience or study now our generation I
think was more realistic because our
parents have been power of the
depression World War two the Holocaust
was huge really so we who had a sense of
reality about what what is important
what is barbaric in human history
and this idea that you can micromanage
reality down to the pleasant it's a kind
of Doris Day view of of existence it's
like so reactionary people don't realize
it said it's sentimental it's middlebrow
and it's not belong and they are so
sanctimonious about it the sanctimony
alone is enough to drive you mad and and
what the students are doing now and this
is an Oxford University and I think you
you know about this the young women are
demanding trigger warnings for any
anything that's but you know violent or
unpleasant in a classroom and so I'm
thinking again
trigger warnings in a history class
because you're I think it's something of
law oh yes and they had to do with like
rape cases they had to have a trigger
warning you will there's a group of
professors at Harvard Law School who are
opposed to this because they have young
women who are going to be studying law
for some of them to be litigators but
they do not want to hear even the word
violate they've been asked to excise
upsetting terms and huh well this is
what is this what what kind of world are
we going to have when these people
graduate so progressive it's like they
were the era of the Hollywood studio
production code when violence was also
you know censored out not just sex and
that's why I Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho
in 1960 you know change that changed
modern film and opened it to you know
all kinds of representations of the
reality of human human existence I think
that you know from what I can see most
feminists seem to lack a sense of the of
psychopathology they don't understand
the most extreme manifestations of human
psychology so say they again they think
they can micromanage everything they
think that they can somehow a fine tune
the entire world to be entirely safe
okay the world will never be entirely
safe okay for any human being male or
female the idea that somehow a girl
going out at night alone is going to as
long as everyone who's graduated from
the elite school okay be somehow
protected against an attack from from a
mania from a mania
and if that if you tell a young woman
you should not get a you know bit you
should not binge drink and then and then
go out and you know walk around you you
will you're courting danger
oh we tell men not to rape don't tell us
what we act on blaming the victim if you
try to give good advice to be street
smart about how you dress and how you
behave in to be aware of your
environment and know how to handle
yourself in a potentially dangerous
environment it's called blaming the
victims men are predators but there are
predators among men there are it's truly
insane people the human mind is it
remains primitive the human mind remains
half animal and of course if you
completely remove biology from from your
consideration then you've got everything
that you know with this kind of Girl
Scout code they they have like girl
scout you know view how we're all
socially constructed it's all so we can
just regenerate here they're in this
fantasy world they can they think that
they can produce a sexual utopia with
all of the excitement and interest of
sexual relations comes from potential
danger guess what gay men have known
this for thousands of years
gay men go out everywhere around the
world okay in court danger and death
okay every time they pick up a rough
trade on the street it happens all the
time
do you hear gay men complaining all the
time when two gay men trying to
micromanage the entire world so they can
pick up and strangers okay in meeting
bus terminals okay without danger no gay
men find the danger a kick now why is it
then that men ok have that kind of more
sophisticated sexuality but no girls are
still girls are still children we must
always protect them ok they're tender
flower or is it is a so regressive okay
this is not feminism nor is it modernism
torreón it's a victorious and it's also
you takes an independent is full of so
many bad ideas that should have been
laughed out of court what it for example
this idea of the male gaze and they use
this that's you know woman is treated as
object passes Laura matings idea exactly
from 1970s okay absolutely
it just polluted film criticism and
Laura móvil is a very nice person I've
met her at the British Film Institute in
London
I think my change dilution knows nothing
about the visual arts you cannot just
you know wade into film criticism and
start talking about the male gaze
without knowing something about the
history of art okay in a perspective in
a vision and so on I mean the male gaze
is a foolish idea should have a longer
been discarded and it's not as if in gay
culture there we don't find the male
gaze I mean gay males enjoy looking at
and pictures of beautiful idealized gay
and there you have just put disproved to
stupid theory okay because gay men know
when they look at a beautiful young man
okay that they are not making creating
some sort of powerful subordination okay
you know on that man okay they know
they're looking up in admiration and
does that beauty at that beauty which is
a part of Western art since the Greeks
and it's a I mean men look at women and
it and and yes they're enjoying but
they're also often intimidated it's a
very intimate and biologically okay it
appears to be that the visual apparatus
is much more connected to male sexuality
than female terms and this is why women
this we're going to understand they
think they can put on every kind of sexy
costume and it's merely decor that I
think it does not carry its own message
right right it's nothing right they did
because they don't see things as
visually as men do okay but I don't know
whether I have the male gaze or what but
I stowed under stand this I mean a
second trends charge in female sexuality
with women today young women they want
to wield the power of female sexuality
without it without then accepting any of
the consequences of it that's right and
and it's you I think what we're seeing
now on the campus is we have this hyper
Puritanism this policing of sexuality
and then all of these functionaries they
operate chicks the universities there I
read University of North Carolina has 40
or 50 sexual harassment sexual assault
what a waste of money no work shoppers
and they're busy they go back parasites
they go back and forth to conferences
they get new ideas and and you know it
used to be that the lot of the theories
we objected to they were inspired I
don't know by French philosophy and
there was a lot of
obscure nonsense now a lot of the
scholarship is driven by these
apparatchiks some of functionaries in
university and their little findings of
which is all propaganda advocacy
research so they find that up you know
turns out that swathmore is a rape
culture okay where on earth are women
we've been safer but they know they now
these these sexual harassment assault
counselors they go to they have fact
books and you know little videos and
they they bring kids in for orientation
and tell them they they actually
describe the campus it's as dangerous at
at Oberlin and and and Wesleyan is is
that is war-torn Congo and young men so
the the young women are frightened yeah
and so they've introduced so much
paranoia
yeah and the bureaucrats and the culture
of blame and you can a young man can be
destroyed yes because simply by being
accused is a kangaroo courts in the
kangaroo court the bureaucrats have
taken over the universities the faculty
have also had very critically lost power
over the past thirty to forty years and
the faculty has been utterly passive and
not pushing back against all of this
where have they been you know when we
were talking with money other way twenty
years ago twenty-one years ago I thought
for sure more scholars would come
forward because I do believe that this
this panic this this you know salem
witch trial atmosphere it was created by
scholars working with with the
university functionaries but it's going
to take scholars to stop it where are
they yes that's right
they're afraid there's a fear okay now
okay you once your tangle with the
bureaucrats they have all the power now
okay there's no no and now with federal
regulations behind it this is it I'm
hoping Congress I'm gonna roll this back
this is this is this over interpretation
of title nine back in the nineteen
ninety-seven we were winning the
argument and we had the support of the
media and they were all these great
writers that took our side Pro free
speech I mean it was taken for great
and people would make fun of the courses
they would look at the MLA and there
would be these silly courses on I don't
know cross-dressing in medieval Valencia
or auto-erotic ISM in the early Jane
Austen right right and it was it was fun
and then the media I think got a little
tired of and thought it had gone away it
didn't go away it got much worse and if
you look at the curriculum now the
courses that kids take it there's a on
Twitter there's a Twitter site called
peer review and all he does is report
abstracts show abstracts in journals
it's so shocking and it never ends and
you think they've reached the ultimate
of madness I mean there was an article
just to give an example and this isn't
the worst feminist Glick glaciology it's
a feminist study of glaciers it draws on
feminist post colonialism and feminist
political ecology
what are these fields what deep there's
a field feminist politically caught what
do they read and it must just be slogans
and and you know mixed with a little
propaganda a little paranoia thrown in
one course after the other so are they
taking history of Western civilization
are they're learning about art do they
know major historical figures no but
they know they could talk about you know
these arcane little propagandistic
topics yes aside the core curriculum was
it was abandoned okay as these news of
micro fields came in women's studies
after in American Studies and so on and
identity politics seemed sort of changed
the curriculum in 1970s so then then all
of a sudden the whole history of Western
art well that's you know that's a
classes that's racist said oh we have to
abandon that and so what you have now is
a whole generation in fact two
generations probably of graduate
students who are incapable actually of
ever teaching in the broad narrative way
the old one wonderful survey courses now
what I'm calling for a is an attack upon
the curriculum a reduction by sixty
percent of it all these elected city
electives thrown out okay and at a
compulsory return okay to teaching
within this core this
these core ideas that are oriented
toward ancient to modern because another
thing that in addition to what you just
mentioned a fragmentation is that too
many courses now are dated in the
present and the present from after the
Enlightenment or even after the 19th
century okay so you have a real
imbalance in the curriculum so that
young people have no sense okay of the
ancient civilizations and the way they
rose and fell okay over time they have
no idea of the world they think that all
the evils of the world are isolated in
Western culture they don't they have no
idea about the atrocities and the
oppressions of empires all over the
world world I thought so what we what we
need to do I discover many in my
students coming from a broad range of
preparations from an inference now and
then there'll be a private school
student but mostly they come from good
suburban school or from bad you know
inner-city schools and they know
absolutely nothing about about the above
a chronology of human life okay and it's
a hence they they look around them and
they see things that are flaws in our
current system and they believe that
these flaws can be fixed and that all
other cultures in history or in the
world we're somehow a paradise on earth
we're enjoying alters the most liberties
Evers and women all these students who
are so hostile to the United States
because it's a capitalist cícero
patriarchal oppressive imperialist
system these sorts of terms are taken
seriously well compared to what what
other country I mean we're far from
perfect but we're a struggling democracy
that's done more to address racism and
classism and and sexism and then any
country I'm aware of and but it's almost
if they don't know that and they don't
know that will we have experimented with
systems you know that aren't don't have
free markets and they didn't work out
very well this students don't seem to
know that they don't know the history of
communism they have no sense of
economics or Economic Area to recede
yeah and so they're very confidently
have and they've been taught by in their
classes and what astonishes me is a
someone who's a professor of many years
I always thought it was a sacred
commandment thou shalt teach
both sides of the argument so in any
philosophy class I would make sure
whatever we were setting I tried to
bring you know the best foot was thought
and said on both sides well in these
classrooms in many classrooms it could
be an especially anthropology sociology
not philosophy philosophy is so far
immune to this although it has other
problems literature throughout the human
literature and then of course Gender
Studies all the ethnic studies classes
it's largely one point of view I mean
they have their doctrinal feuds but it's
the gamut from A to B they leave out all
other perspectives conservatives aren't
there haven't forbid libertarian
perspectives not their common sense has
no place and so the students have this
this sense that they've been exposed to
you know the what is you know they take
to be settled knowledge it's not settled
yes well there's another thing I'm
calling for is that is that the
profession has not paid its sufficient
attention to this question of advocacy
in the classroom and in the way yeah I
think that it's important that teachers
have opinions or inside the classroom
however they have an obligation epical
and professional obligation to identify
what they're saying as opinion okay an
end to state openly to the class that
every person in the class has the right
to express a contrary opinion and to
hold it without the the rest of the
class scorning it or creating a in a
hostile environment etc right but that's
totally gone from the profession look at
the idea the ethics of teaching the
ethics of teaching okay as well as the
ethics of research are no longer a
subject of study okay by the profession
itself oh this is very important to
bring back and and just in terms of
effective teaching what I love to do
because I loved it as a student you'll
remember this it is especially true in
philosophy you would read a set of
philosophers let's suppose philosophers
defending free will in a metaphysics
course and you would you know you tend
to agree with them as you read them then
the teacher would switch and you'd read
the determinists and the critiques and
then you would think how was I ever how
did I ever believe that and you have
that wonderful intellectual experience
of changing your mind or realizing that
I'd been wrong now I'm right
maybe I'm wrong and then you have this
you develop this senses some humility
that you have to you know take into
account a full range of opinion this is
what I did in my philosophy classes what
every textbook I ever saw in philosophy
does this but one occasion and this is
probably what prompted me to start
criticizing feminism the chair of my
department asked me to teach women's
studies course feminist theory and I
sent away for textbooks and I thought
okay I'll teach it I mean I can a
feminist I'm a philosopher I'll teach
feminist philosophy I assumed I don't
know what I thought I thought it would
be I mean those historical figures
saying some terrible things and some
good things and then I thought maybe it
was people pro and con abortion or
surrogate motherhood affirmative action
know what it was it's a series of rather
paranoid texts these were the these were
feminist philosophers writing these
smart women really but they were
ideologues the the readings were
mutually reinforcing right and there was
a lot of false data that's where I
became I alert to the way that role
propaganda you take these sensitive
mostly young women and these Women's
Studies classes they hear that one in
four of them will be raped that they're
going to be cheated out of 25 percent of
their salary you know they'll have a
massive loss of self-esteem and that's
only if they're not already dead from an
eating disorder caused by you know
patriarchal standards of beauty they
learn this and this is these sorts of
things were in the textbooks and I was
just appalled and that the lack of
balance and as I said the the propaganda
and the ideology so that's what I went
to the American Philosophical
Association read a paper criticizing and
I thought like other times I'd been
there you argue it's it's combat and I
was prepared for that and then and then
you go out for drinks that's typically
what happens well we did not go out for
drinks the room was full of feminist
philosophers some were hissing stamping
their feet and I was excommunicated from
a religion I didn't know
and then it was year or two after that I
think I was reading the New York Times
and it was about this woman Camille poly
uh it wasn't true I wasn't sure how to
pronounce it and I I was riveted and
soon after you spoke at MIT and I went
it was a rainy night I went out it was
at Brookline and a little child at home
but I would there was nothing to keep me
away and the room was filled it were all
of MIT and already they had video tapes
in the video cameras and also students
could I mean screen so students could
say people came from all over on the
Boston area or is there the police there
to handle the crowd at least and I think
that evening you may have deprogrammed
you know a thousands do you were there
and you were just telling the truth
well half half of the crowd was it was
against half was for and I felt like I
was like steering a ship on a stormy sea
and I guess of my best improv comedy
ever met night I just put that was these
days we'd have you in YouTube billions
so there's a transcript of it okay in
mine it was one of the startling
intellectual experiences of my life and
for all those students and and I
remember there were a group of people I
forget they had a name for themselves
they were all dressed in black and
they're funny and they came to protest
your views I guess on date rape or
something and they came and they were
going to make trouble but then they were
so outnumbered and they were sort of
mesmerised by you and I sort of watched
as they quietly melted away and so
because they were very used to
disrupting speakers who read prepared
texts and I do improv game in
controversial situations and it's very
difficult to deal with it they're
everything negative that came from the
floor I would just like do something
with it and throw it right back I was
training trained in the school of Joan
Rivers
oh that's God as my witness I will not
read a speech again it's just not not on
can't no it's actually not a good idea
it's better just to talk to the audience
so this is what happened a couple of
weeks ago went to UMass Amherst and and
we I was there with Milo gianopolous
who is this provocateur satirist
self-described [ __ ] poster and just
funny and he says provocative things
very very amusing to me not to everyone
and I have to correct him he does go too
far so he's sort of like the it's not
really good cop bad cop it's more like
concerned mother and wayward son and we
go to camp we've gone to a few campuses
together and then we had a comedian this
wonderful comedian Steve Crowder there
were three of us as soon as we come on
people in the audience you know they're
there they're dispersed around they
start screeching and yelling and and
then Milo says something and he's done
he's doing what you say he makes them I
won't repeat what Milo said but that
provoked him and then I went up as based
mom you know to be to be reasonable I
thought well I accept them even but they
were screaming even more they were using
a foul language so it's all on tape so
it's kind of gone viral
but there was not a moment that they
weren't screaming and no you know I
don't know where the campus police were
apparently this is permitted but we at
one point Milo said we're not going away
we're here we're gonna give our talk and
then the comedian did this little riff
he was angry at them and that's also
gone viral on the and the Internet but
my hope is that so this has all been
covered by the conservative press not a
word in the New York Times not a word in
in in the New Republic or on you know
slate no one's the the liberal media is
not paying attention so I'm very
concerned that I mean last time we had
the help of the liberal media and that
didn't work so maybe not having them
maybe it doesn't matter but I'm just
sort of wondering when the you know
who's going to come forward and defend
just free speech mm-hmm where is that
right now well it movement where than
that hint at woman and tough is still
there but in those days we had just so
many people coming forward in defending
free speech and you had then you had
people I think there has to be pressure
on the
on the colleges and universities
themselves to maintain an atmosphere for
civil discourse and for for hospitality
chicken to guests of any political
persuasion and without that kind of
backbone okay in the coming from the
college administrators themselves I
think this is going to go on but I think
I feel that there's slowly a sense of
things turning that the seriousness of
it okay it started aware that this is
really getting absurd now and I also
think some of the the not some I think a
lot of the Millennials who sort of
because they it's a scrappy generation
and it's also they're all connected and
the internet and so they talk to each
other I we haven't heard from them yet I
think every generation you know faces a
threat to freedom you always have to
fight for it I mean in the 50s you had
the McCarthy era and the earlier
generations there you know there's
always movements that come along and
have good reasons why someone should
have to shut up and keep quiet and at
these censorship campaigns mmm-hmm so
this generation is being challenged and
and I think we there I'm seeing signs of
rebellion mmm-hmm but I don't think
students realize they're that kind of
power that they have for for pushback
against the college administration's
they know they don't you know they they
keep on accepting all of these
paternalism that's kind of suffocating
all enveloping paternalism okay and I
think they should the activists these
social justice warriors on campus they
know the power they have over in
ministry yes that's right someone taped
a young woman going into an office in
Vassar at Vassar College demanding that
a copy of that it was a setup I mean it
was someone filming this this poor
administrator really so this sort of
pretend student went in with a copy of
the US Constitution and it was at Vassar
and she wanted it shredded because it
was it was triggering and and the media
had the conservative media had a good
time with it because it was showing that
here's a an administrator that would
shred the Constitution that's not what I
saw in the tape I saw a frightened
administrator terrified that this of
this young woman probably thinking am I
going to lose my job if this doesn't and
she would have she was a hostage
this administrator was like a frightened
hostage and this is what I think I think
that so so what I want the Millennials
to understand the social justice
activists and these the the trigger you
know the safe space people on campus
they are pressuring and frightening the
administrators who are giving in to them
which is nothing they should administer
aters should be proud of but it's time
for a pushback from the the students who
value free speech who value rational
scholarship who would like to be free
individuals and and to stop the the
policing of sexuality all of these
things have to be fought for again
that's right absolutely yeah so yeah it
has to be a new movement a new free
speech movement in my in my view it has
to be it has to come from the students
as it did the first time with Mario sabe
I was just gonna say in the Mario Savio
and they at that time they had a lot to
lose too and so because that's what the
students will tell you they'll tell you
you know it you college is so expensive
and if I get in trouble and and now you
can be marked as you know a rape culture
apologist or a racist simply by
challenging simply by asking for an open
debate you can be there's a lot of the
administrators are you know they are now
running essentially a business okay look
at the colleges are all competitive with
each other they're desperate for tuition
dollars so they the bureaucrats are all
about protecting the you know the PR
image of the university so they want to
be on the undisputedly correct side of
protecting those who have suffered from
from racial or gender injustice in the
past etc I mean there really is this
kind of hazing speak of sanctimonious is
this at this you know puffed up view of
themselves is somehow part okay of the
progressive movement of social justice
in the universe okay by suppressing
people of dissident views and on campus
you can't even get there there are and
I've been writing about this for years
as you know there's now this set of it's
just a body of egregiously false
information at the heart of campus
radical isn't particularly campus
feminism
and in 21 years ago we were talking
about false statistics on rape false
statistics on the wage gap this wage gap
still going on will never go away
ridiculous and this one status often
said a phony statistic is harder to kill
than a vampire you know once it's out in
the me a false feminist statistic is the
hardest to kill of all it's unbelievable
it is beyond the reach of rational
analysis no one understands that you
know that for heaven's sakes John
Kennedy signed the equal pay you know
bill looks like it's like decades ago
with F century ago and then there's just
the very rare cases of a woman being
paid less than a man for doing the same
job okay right so simple no there's no
bountiful economist would tell you
otherwise
Lorne and yet when I say this on campus
and I you know shrieks and and and and
you know some young woman at at Oberlin
I remember you know saying well if you
want to make as much as a mensch man
check you know you should change your
major because on average men are more
likely to study these highly you know
remunerative fields petroleum
engineering or naval architecture and I
just said to the Oval and say you know
if you study feminist dance therapy you
might not earn as much oh my goodness
they were outraged and at the idea that
they couldn't study what they want and
then earn as much and so forth and they
carry on but there's there it's so we've
got this propaganda there's no way to
correct it and then you get outed down
on campus if you even you know the
biggest gap in in women's studies is the
failure to have a requirement about
biology oh well there's no reference to
biology you've had learn now 40 years of
women's studies right whether with a
social constructionist view of gender
okay without without the slightest
reference to hormones or endocrinology
you know the 40 years of women's studies
and I think we know less about gender we
started for this very reason this Dogma
oh that men and women are the same that
are cognitively interchangeable
we rely slates at birth and society
inscribes gender on us yes yes absurd
this is one one feminist philosopher
said many years ago we're all born
bisexual and then through socialization
were transformed into gendered
human beings one destined damat to
command the other to obey so I once read
that to to my husband who said which one
commands and which obey there you go I
mean premise six I'm someone who wrote
was writing a dissertation on in drogyny
okay and I never for one moment in my
entire life have question of the sexes
are actually different and that there
aren't there it's a very powerful
hormonal compulsion that drives the
sexes together for procreation hello
okay and people say well what's the
evidence well let's start with the
entire anthropological record or just go
into any and just look at a magazine
rack and it's clear that men are looking
on average I'm not talking about all men
and all women but on average there are
different propensity men have eight to
ten times the amount of testosterone
okay circulating in their in their
bodies than women do right I mean if
there aren't consequences from them of
course that this subject is something
oddly untouched okay in gender studies
you can graduate with a degree in
women's studies know nothing about it
nothing nothing to know and and so they
are at any time they find statistical
disparity between men and women any
field if there are more male you know
petroleum engineers it has to be
discrimination right it can't be women's
free choice for any reason choice and
that on average women are interested in
other things absolutely and and also
women want more flexibility in their
lives to allow for children but that's
not also part of the feminine oh we
don't have a special bond with children
is if the I mean it's so absurd the
denial of nature the denial of
femininity and masculinity which for
most people it you know it it's a source
of enjoyment and and and you know in if
you in if you are conventionally
feminine you enjoy that typically and
the same with with male and you enjoy
them a masculine man and all of this is
now sort of either denied or there's
this aura of disapproval around
conventional sexuality and and there's
there's a little pushback in the Academy
and so it's because there's no knowledge
ok then people don't people are just
settled ok and sluggish within their
little cells
ideological cells and they they really
are very few truly inquiring minds left
okay
no no true intellectuals okay really in
the Academy the Academy is now across
the collagen in universities I've never
been known for producing free thinkers
okay that's it is after all bureaucratic
you know an entity the Academy but
that's well if we want intellectuals
this is the present system is certainly
not the way to produce them
oh I'm just wondering where you know
what is this generation are we gonna
have some great public intellectuals
coming forth I know who aren't just
spouting dogs it's a low ebb would allow
people to have it have free and
independent thought but no oh no you
have all these people you know these
these little Turner mobs that are
policing everyone you know you'll have I
mean these incidents this poor comet
scientist who wore the wrong shirt to a
press conference and then oh they were
hysterical and on the internet to to
punish him and censure him and these
kinda funky ilysm of their minds the
banality of their minds why aren't more
people like us why don't more people see
we have a product of a certain time okay
we I realized that now I I'm trying
actually not to be too hard okay and the
young people today because they didn't
have our kind of background okay our you
know our paranoid and the comedian's of
Memorial and Lenny Bruce and then George
Carlin comedian and then Richard Pryor
and so today the comedians aren't
allowed on campus yes that's right
triggering when they don't want a go
humor comes from violating taboos okay
if you have a taboo it would about women
or a race or anything else then you then
you're attracting humor toward it I mean
any rigidity attracts humor is it
because set our breaks up okay the
rigidity so anyway my my question here
is there's so I think this you know
these this propaganda and the denial
that there are differences between the
sexes they've just built up this it's a
it's a big lie and it's almost to me
comparable I can't carry out this
analogy too far but like the that the
credit default swaps and there was all
this these bad more
distributed everywhere no one knew where
they were but they were everywhere in
the economy and then it brought it down
and I see this this is like this
feminist misinformation we have feminist
misinformation about in every area
disseminated by these these credulous
journalists who don't ask the right
question
so everybody believes sexes are exactly
the same everything though that there's
this wage gap that there's this rape
culture on campus that women are you
know victims in men are all of this is
out there large numbers of people
believing something that's just not true
you have to realize a lot of people in
the media now our products of those PCI
elite schools I encountered them all the
time okay and trying to get their minds
to focus they have utterly I mean I'm
talking about Yale degrees Harvard's
prefer giri's don't work degree the more
lower it is absolutely their mind their
might like holy generation can focus
young women have no knowledge they've
been missing they're in they're in the
mania they're writing in The New York
Times or doing political analysis in the
New York Times they know nothing they
know nothing but they have a lot of
confidence very high self-esteem yes no
problem they have these like bright and
shiny degrees which are which are in
fact meaningless and valueless worthless
worthless degrees worth worthless Ivy
League degrees they should go back they
should go I don't know the price you say
then I only wolf her parents should have
sued Yale education Sue's abilities
parents authority in Niomi these are
these are two very smart women okay who
are defrauded by their elite school
education
look how their careers have tanked why
is that they didn't have the solid
rigorous education you and I did I went
to the prom I went to the University of
New York at Binghamton I had a superb
education in the basics and that is that
is fueling my productivity at my stage
of life but look at the Susan Faludi
Naomi Wolf okay
they start out so strong and there's
nothing because they have nothing
underneath it and I identify them with
him in this way when I I came from
Southern California in the hippy area a
hippie era I was a flower child and you
know so if I had come to college and
they had courses I think have courses in
witchcraft I was interested in that my
friend in high school was Mimi Simoes
she became a witch she was a brilliant
girl but chic became Starhawk and I
don't know we were friends of adventure
became I mean maybe we could still be
friends
I wouldn't want her to put a hex on me
but but it's but I went to NYU and I
would if they'd had cookie majors I
would have got you know in for them I
would have been a witchcraft major i
thinkin maybe but the the most
interesting thing I could find was
philosophy and my philosophy professors
at NYU it was clear thinking and rigor
and precision rules and and coming as a
you know flower I thought it was far out
yeah I thought it was they were so we
went we read this book language truth
and logic by a jair it was a very
extreme kind of a statement of the need
for a logical rigor in your thought and
so forth and I just felt I loved it I
fell in love with it and I slowly class
after class I had you know reading the
great philosophers and and I slowly
became a discipline think or I like to
think that I did but but I always knew
you know what I how I won't see the
world saw the world and then the
transformation of course that's what I
hope to do in the classroom what I see
now is that that you know that
seventeen-year-old eighteen year old
Christina coming from the California
flower child culture and a lot of kids
are coming from all sorts of Akron say
they come to school it would be
reinforced it would be catered to I
couldn't you know and and you could run
to the D I could have run to the Dean
and say well not you know I'm not really
giving the courses that I would like to
say you can design your own major ins
cafeteria style the cafeteria yeah and
you know it's even in the museum's now
oh absolutely I just just recently in
the museum's I was in Portland - my
never mind why I was in Portland and I
went to the the local museum and there
was a beautiful display of some Indian
artifacts and some of some exquisite
photographs of Indians and Native
Americans and in the the works of art
supply was all beautiful but on every in
every room there was a some you know
feminist our historian had written a
hectoring little description censoring
you know censuring and and
talking about the the you know the gaze
of the tourists and and you know this is
all this kind of deconstruction and so
you couldn't you couldn't just didn't
you couldn't learn about the art and you
couldn't enjoy it
it had to be mediated through the mind
of this fanatic ideologue to be filtered
through right the judgmentalism the
moralism the guilt-tripping and so on
you know is that an actual encounter
with some artifact from the from the
past in a sense of awe okay in reverence
before that object no we have to here we
have you have this interposed
contemporary figure a heck doing us
exactly yes yeah so that's we serve and
then their new preachers then you know
Marlon skulls their goals their pest and
but it's now not so what we see it going
into the media that's a given and now in
the museum's and and then there's this
cultural appropriation this is one of
the new ideas that you know if you the
you know at some level a lot of us has
there's that there's a kernel of wisdom
that you know you don't put on blackface
and you know and and you know
essentially demean another culture in
that way but now they're going after
yoga classes and you know that sort of
thing you're not supposed to say namaste
that's going to put all of Portland out
of work it's nothing but yoga studios
but I don't know but in now performances
of The Mikado the Gilbert and Sullivan
people are saying well that was cultural
appropriation it's demeaning you had a
museum in Boston where they have
beautiful kimonos and on display and you
can have you know
well now that's there were protesters
and the protesters don't seem to be from
it's almost always people that aren't in
that culture that are the most shrill
and so the Boston Museum the Museum of I
had to apologize
oh so this is going on so it's you know
it's permeating the culture and I want
it to stop
yes that's right right so it's so
unsophisticated okay this isn't it this
is not the way intellection this is not
the way you had you contemplate history
and arsh okay through these you know the
contemporary felt a political filter
that
this is a it distorts the true meaning
of history and our realises in tribulus
and that's what I see with students
they're not having these encounters with
great works of art right that's what a
teacher should we were you're produced
by a great books correctly always had no
matter what even if you had a bad
teacher you always had a classic mm-hm
and so they in a sense of respect for
the greatness of the work not this
debunking sharing the construction
you're exactly oh this is like a product
of all kinds of a outmoded or racial or
gender paradigms and so on give me a
break okay yeah the whole history of the
world is seen through this contemporary
lens and again it's it's absolutely you
know and that's why we're not getting
any important intellectuals and young
intellectuals young writers young
analysts okay you if you're ever gonna
get any they have got to start going
back to the library and finding other
independent thinkers because they're
certainly not being presented with them
in the in the classroom they're just not
know so they're that's the message
you're going to students today you
cannot depend on your don't depend on
the teachers teacher no this distrust
Authority resist Authority and go and
find what you need in the library and
don't just sit there on your ear and in
front of the computer because the
computer self-selects you know for you
okay you know you're not gonna find out
you have to go and physically engage
with the things on the shelves that's
what I did i ransacked thing you know
the University Library and and our
universities have been sewn called our
universities islands of repression in a
sea of freedom students have to liberate
their islands so we're here to ferment
rebellions right that's right well thank
you can be yellow gray Christina as
usual we already agree 20 years from now
and oh goodness that's right okay it
it'll all be it'll be free again
liberated and let's hope free speech is
restored yes and insanity well thank you
you